so i had my first blood transfusion
which sounds so much more dramatic than
it is
um it's just like an iv but accepted
except not fluids it's
human blood chrissy teigen has now had
multiple blood transfusions after being
hospitalized sunday for pregnancy
complications
i kind of feel like i definitely have
somebody else
inside me right now
which is odd failing to have
on tuesday morning the 34 year old tv
personality gave fans an
update on twitter writing quote just had
a really scary
morning huge clot almost save worthy
the scramble to hear the heartbeat
seemed like hours i never thought i'd
relieve psy
so much in my life the message on
twitter came just hours after chrissy
shared updates on her instagram story
of course always infusing her signature
sense of humor
it just made me think of like oh whose
blood is this and also
like i bet there's so many people out
there that would be so mad
if they got my blood like some hardcore
maggot person
they're like this is chrissy's bud
they'd be like no
no also on monday the cookbook author
shared this throwback photo on her
instagram feed
and assured fans in the caption that she
and her baby are completely fine
although chrissy admits she misses
walking cooking and playing with her
kids
luna and miles i'm about like halfway
through pregnancy and um
uh the blood has been going on for like
a month
we're talking like more than your period
girls
every time i would go to the bathroom um
it would be blood but honestly just
laying there would just be blood
that was the sports illustrated model on
sunday getting candid on her instagram
story about her symptoms
today the big difference was that it
kind of was like
if you were to just kind of turn a
faucet
on to low and leave it there and
just kind of leave it but even so
chrissy says she's feeling great
and the baby boy growing in her belly is
healthy and doing well
offering this analogy um basically
he like is the strongest coolest dude in
the
[Music]
house